Andrew Tate has been hospitalized by The
Matrix
the last thing we wanted what happened
well basically he sent out a tweet and
said the Matrix attacked me and then
there's like a news leak that's
basically out saying that he was
transported to the hospital no one knows
if any of this is necessarily true or
not and no one even knows who tweeted
from the account because he's been
detained Matrix wants to be passing true
but then the information came out
that
he had oh [ __ ] where was it I remember
screenshot it did um
he had like a medical condition
that he had already notified them of so
he went to the hospital to seek help for
the medical conditions I didn't know
that so it wasn't I I've been a tag that
yeah I don't know I might want to cut
this but uh did you see a true geordies
one of the brothers uh was claimed to
have a pre-existing health issue that he
told a medic about which led to him
being taken to the hospital Daily Mail
reports hmm
so I I I I I want to I want to go in the
true Jordan because you Joy did a whole
[ __ ] thing about him lighting him up
yeah it's uh it's really interesting
like a few different things can be true
about this he can be an incredibly
engaging speaker have interesting
thoughts about gender identity and know
how to package them in a way that just
lights the internet on fire be
incredible at debate when it comes to
these types of things and also be funny
and
also maybe be involved in some shady
dealings with women in the sex cam
business and uh maybe the treatment of
them all these things can be true and I
think people are like using one to
discredit the other when they're
completely unrelated like you can have a
lot of knowledge about gender Dynamics
and know how to communicate it while
also maybe potentially if treated some
women shitty and guess what also treated
women well there could be women that are
vouching for you that you did really
treat well yeah yeah like so all these
things can be true and I think like when
you really are impacted by someone and
really like love someone and and you've
started to like craft your identity
around them you want to defend them
because you're really defending yourself
yeah yeah if your identity is interwoven
with it honestly it's like you don't
same thing happens to Jordan Peterson of
course like people will rip on him and
that people will defend him to the death
and it's like you gotta acknowledge like
sometimes his tweets are crazy and
out-of-pocket yeah like unnecessary yeah
they won't even see it because they're
so tied up into his identity yeah which
I I think even he would say and I think
anyone would say yo don't make my my
message the only thing that you think
about in your life Jordan would be the
first person to tell you that yeah he'd
be like that's the most dangerous thing
that's what leads to tyranny yeah you've
created this like parasocial
codependency that is not necessary
healthy yeah 100 and Andrew say is like
the same thing where people wrap
themselves so much and they can't
acknowledge this rap song sucks that
it does though right like no it's not
too bad it wasn't bad it wasn't bad
[ __ ] red pill dude
I told you about Sunday for hustle's
University last week I'm doing it yeah
opposite of a cup that show was bad yeah
that [ __ ] was bad but was it like right
on a curve what was it like I'm I'm
watching this and I'm like what [ __ ]
idiot what who does a [ __ ] song and
put music video like what a [ __ ]
loser right and then he's an alpha War
actually open her up
no but so so what I was wondering is
like if he's doing it sarcastically like
if he's doing in the way that that we
did open her up are we just having fun
it's awesome if he's just having fun
then it's awesome if he's doing it where
he's like I need to be famous whether
I'm going to be on Big Brother or
whether I'm going to be on this thing
whether I'm going to do music
Something's Gonna Make me famous I'm
gonna find a way to be famous that's
crazy because that'd be so good at so
many things
it is rare it is rare that kind of
talent yeah yeah rap kickboxing
kickboxing kickboxing talking buying
cars yeah nobody's been able to buy cars
like that right he says it Bugatti fire
pronouncing no yeah sick pronunciation
of words right pronounced chess
yeah I think he actually is good at
chess he's good at chess yeah but uh but
yeah yeah it's just it's it is one of
those kind of peculiar things where it's
like okay
if this is all about like what gets me
on and what makes me famous because I
have a desire to be famous then you
start to look through everything through
a different lens yeah at least that's
how I would kind of do it if you do it
to just make a funny video kind of tease
himself and like this would be a
hilarious thing to just put out then I'm
like okay that's kind of great yeah cool
content you're willing to make yourself
look dumb and you know you look dumb
yeah yeah it didn't look like that
though it did look like that you can
still make the song good too though
that's what Lil Dicky did he was like
I'm gonna make a song that's like funny
and kind of silly you can't compare in a
little Dicky you gotta compare him like
Jason Kidd you know what I mean wait
what Kobe Bryant the guys who wrapped as
like the athletes like there are other
things and then they just come out I
think Jason good at one I know Kobe had
an um had an album yeah Kobe wrapped
dude there's a whole time
I think Shaq started
actually had a fire one weirdly like for
a ball player oh and I guess it had a
[ __ ] song come out that [ __ ] was fire
then they said a couple select words and
they're like you're not a rapper no more
yeah yeah
yeah yeah so then so what's the thing
like I think it's a tricky one
especially for tape because I think a
lot of people are looking for
there's probably a lot of young men this
is the over correction right it's like a
lot of young men
probably feel
probably feel like they they're uh
there's no voice for their emotional
reaction to the popularity of feminism
and the positions that they're that are
being taken by Ultra feminists and
there's no like logical reaction for it
I think Jordan probably has taken some
and a lot of people followed Jordan
Peterson because of that and then Tate
came in with like the most Kevin Samuels
came in you've seen a lot of these guys
and like they're the over correction
which is like oftentimes when nobody's
speaking out the loudest voice is going
to get listened to and the loudest voice
might not be like the most nuanced
specific one that can take on this issue
and it can go over the noise if a bunch
of people are speaking the guy who
speaks the loudest can go over the noise
yeah yeah and yeah and I think people
are tapping into not only that but like
yeah I think men in general in America I
mean we've talked about this before just
have [ __ ] are in like a crisis a
little yeah it feels like but I think
it's touching on like part of the
inequalities that exist against men that
people don't really acknowledge because
it's not trendy ever but like the dude
that [ __ ] if you are in a custody
dispute even if the mother's abusive you
might not get your kids that's not fair
even not feminists would agree it's not
fair yes but the fact that it's not
acknowledged that's where people start
getting crazy and then they're run into
the arms of [ __ ] snake oil salesmen
that are like yeah I'll promise you
everything yeah and you like we were
talking about before I forget who you
overlook all the dubious [ __ ] because
they're saying the thing that you agree
on yeah exactly and you self-select your
brains will just lock into the thing
that's true and forget all the [ __ ] it's
like all the [ __ ] guys are the people
who hate Jews the anti-stemites all of a
sudden found Kanye as like the most
genius artist of our time yeah when he
was saying the anti-jew [ __ ] yeah they
were saying anything before when he was
like when he was like George Bush
doesn't care about black people all
those people are real quiet yeah right
they were like this is on it this guy's
the truth the second he was saying that
anti-jew [ __ ] they're like well who am
out yeah you know what I mean the music
ain't that bad like this Kanye gets it
so I think I think I think what's
happening here like you know with
you know with the gender the gender
conversation
I think what's often happening is
there isn't enough discussion about
biological impulse versus uh societal
impulse so like what is affecting us and
why do we behave in the way that we
behave is it biology or is it society
and I think that anything that's
inconvenient to you male or female you
want to chalk up to societal right you
want to go this is just Society so let's
change it let's remove the stigma
because it's inconvenient to me right
like let's say for example if you're a
dude that's kind of short you wanna I'm
not looking at you but I'm not no look
at that but like let's say if you do a
short you want to be like it's just
Society Society has told women that tall
guys are more attractive let's get rid
of that that's stigma that's [ __ ]
that's Prejudice let's remove the
prejudice against shortcuts when in
reality there might be a biological
evolutionarily a taller bigger guy is
going to make a woman feel safer and
more protected absolutely and because
right so it's like but naturally as a
dude you want to go we can change those
things that would benefit me and make my
life yes and I think one thing happening
then you see like you know taking a lot
of other guys talking about this but
like there's a lot of women out there
who have maybe uh taken up promiscuity
and try to handle it with a certain
amount of bravado yeah they're like well
guys can be promiscuous so why can't we
beat it on the society then and then
that's society that says that we can't
and we should make Society Fair and we
should try to make Society food the
problem is
biology ain't Fair no I don't gotta sit
the piss
biology is just not fair I think Neil
had a great bit he was like a he was
like uh I'm not sexist but Mother Nature
is incredibly sexist or something like a
Bookshare in his premise but and I think
that's one of those tough things where
it's like maybe maybe Society isn't the
one that says that men don't like
promiscuous women maybe biologically we
don't yeah and you you're going uh but
there might be biological reasons for
why men don't want to see overt
promiscuity with women you can accept
that right absolutely and like
that might be completely rejected by an
ultra feminist and that might be really
frustrating for a dude who's like hey I
don't think it's Society telling me this
I just don't want to know about all your
exploits and I don't want to know about
that and and I'm not this insecure loser
because of it I'm the result of millions
of years of selective mating across
every species across every it made me
feel like this so it's like and I think
the problem is now there's a lot of
women who might be you know bragging
about their sexual exploits and might
unfortunately be like suffering the
repercussions of that and they don't
want to acknowledge the reality which is
society or Evolution or biology
selecting them out of the thing that
they might want but I think then they
would get pissed where they're like okay
so biology is supposed to say that we're
supposed to live in tribes of [ __ ] 20
people and do these jobs and you just
did an office and work all day with a
thousand people yeah so you're allowed
to break biology but if I want to [ __ ]
around it's I'm you know it's funny and
that's why we're also generalization
like there are a lot of girls who are
promiscuous that are winning and many
guys want to be with them so it's like I
I don't think like we paint that brush
and I don't think that's there's
exceptions
there's a lot to be exceptions sorry
sorry just to acknowledge this one point
I don't want to like get you know beat
down this point too much but like
Kim Kardashian
we know who her Partners have been but
there's not that many if you really want
to calculate it like we probably know of
like maybe 10 people that maybe Kim has
been in with public the average public
knows and like four of them have been
her husbands but according to the man is
fair that's one too many if you I think
if that's the over correction they want
virgins I think I think that's the over
correction I think that's the
exaggeration that gets all like the you
know it gets everybody's eardrums perked
yeah but uh but I feel like the reality
is is we're talking about the girls who
like I got a hundred bodies I got 300
bodies I'm like the girl who pops up in
some [ __ ] Instagram Tick Tock where
it's like I was sleeping with my
boyfriend then I went to a gas station
and my ex creampied me and then I went
and it's like a guy hearing that uh you
know is gonna go
I don't know if I want to settle down
with that person I think most of us in
this room would say that but the
boyfriend that she's went back to had no
problem with that I think here's what
we're saying that's not true but I don't
think oh they split up yeah she did he
didn't know about it I mean she did it
behind him back now I don't think any of
us are defending red pill type [ __ ]
where it's like the most extreme you can
only have one partner blah blah blah
Society has room to grow and evolve and
we shouldn't just have women oh you can
only have one partner oh we choose your
your husbands Etc but evolutionarily
there is a thing in men based on the
fact that I don't know if a baby is mine
for until like 1980 or whatever
I'd want a girl that has less partners
and I get to have more partners because
that's the only way to ensure I'm having
kids if a girl has a kid she knows it's
his a guy has a girl says hey that's
your baby I just gotta take her word for
it right I get you and that's based on
biology but now Society like we've grown
we've sure and so we can we can progress
to a point but you're asking us to
overcome like Andrew used earlier
millions of years of genetic evolutions
and that's what we have to overcome a
lot of things
this is the argument that people get
into and then it it becomes and I'm not
saying that
what you're saying is wrong I think that
what we're disagreeing on not me and you
like the the argument itself is
basically pinned on how much is biology
and how much his societal and we make
that decision based on how inconvenient
it makes our life and the reality is we
should make that decision based on
what we are actually feeling so it's
very easy to chalk up everything that
you don't want to do anymore to societal
and then I think oftentimes the things
that are for your advantage and men are
guilty of this as well the things that
are for Advantage we don't want to stop
that there's no man right here that's
going babe I want to clean up half the
dishes and I want to do half the cooking
and I want to do whatever we are totally
fine with that societal pressure to have
them I guess nurture Us in that way
right we're not giving any pushback but
we will give pushback if they're trying
to do something that is inconvenient to
us they want to have millions of
Partners to do that kind of stuff so
we're guilty of it so are women but
neither of us are willing to acknowledge
or willing to honestly have the
discussion about about the the
biological [ __ ] in our biological
knee-jerk reaction thanks and I think
that's just what is some of it is
biology and it [ __ ] sucks because it
is unfair and maybe we both just came
together we're like yo this is unfair
but like knowing you've been with 300
dudes actually just makes me feel
uncomfortable and I don't want to handle
it and maybe in a hundred years from now
or a thousand years from now or two
thousand years from now we won't care
maybe I just wish it was one of these
types that didn't package it the way
that the manosphere guys package it or
the way the feminist package right
because because I feel like both sides
are just too like yeah the manosphere is
the equal and opposite reaction to
feminism which is like I should be able
to suck a dick every single morning for
breakfast and then nobody should judge
me for it yeah and it's like well now a
man is fair dude is going to come out
and be like you need to be a virgin
right yeah but somewhere in the middle
is like yeah you should have partners
and be able to like live a life that's
consistent with the technology we have
to protect yourself from getting
impregnated by something that you don't
want while at the same time
recognize that maybe being with two my
people is gonna for whatever reason turn
off and we're talking about millions of
years of dating or mating has created
this way is going to maybe turn off a
Suitor that you might really like
you know what I mean yeah just people
talking like that aren't entertaining
we got the algorithm it's not it's not
as fun to be reasonable like is
it looks about the ship for [ __ ] [ __ ]
years in the most salacious way and it's
way more fun but I now I'm looking at
the way that people are like reacting to
what's going on with Tate and like the
rated almost like young people are
reacting to the content and it weirdly
like on some like OG [ __ ] makes me a
little bit concerned like it's not that
it's not that difficult and people
aren't that far off but nobody's
listening to each other so now it's just
on some [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah
and We're Not Gonna Change Doug oh bro
you put on that hat you're being a real
cowboy dude came a real [ __ ] Southern
gentleman yeah I mean what happened so
what do we do man how do we teach these
kids
I think what you you said a while ago
it's like you almost enter that stage
where you blame women for X Y and Z and
they're this and and you go through that
period and then you have to grow out of
it yeah I don't know we can try to curb
it I guess but I don't know how you
really something you almost have to
learn despite living and yeah and then
finding the right girl and being like oh
oh you're not like trying to manipulate
me you're also just insecure it's like
I'm insecure and let's try to talk and
if she's willing to listen she's the
right person then y'all you'll find that
common ground and then yeah you can have
that in your personal life but it's up
when it seems like in your public life
when people are refuting things are just
so obvious like you know you never have
a conversation yeah men are stronger
than women and then like women be like
well not all and you're like what do you
what what is are we gonna argue this
right now yeah yeah are we gonna argue
that there's not a physical Advantage
the male species like yes there are some
women that are [ __ ] strong and now
you're angry that you even have to
discuss it yeah and that's one you hear
enough of that then like you said
earlier and you go [ __ ] it out I like
the tape dude these [ __ ] this week
they can't open the door you know what I
mean because I'm tired of arguing so I
like that guy yeah yeah yeah this is
It's the we I was talking about this
earlier but it's like this is the
problem this is the problem with
cancellation
cancellation makes the pendulum swing
super far
when you allow someone to have an
alternative idea that's not too crazy
I'm not talking about like Kanye with
the [ __ ] Nazis but I'm talking about
just an idea that's different from you
and you don't even have to agree with it
but just allow it to be here without
getting canceled right if you don't
allow that idea to be here the pendulum
keeps going
yeah right if you allow it it stops here
and it comes back here and back and
forth and back and forth remember how
similar politicians were back in the day
yeah yeah now these [ __ ] on
different planets yeah but back in the
day it was like Clinton Bush you know
what I mean Obama like it was just you
just operate you go Hot Potato right
here and now when you don't even allow
an idea that is even even close to yours
you let that pendulum keep swinging
until you have the most extreme version
that's real [ __ ] loud you're also
only talking to people who think like
you so you're all just moving the
pendulum this way and then they're all
moving their pendulum this way that [ __ ]
just keeps going it's so crazy with uh
presidential candidates they used to
when they're in the primaries they were
running for all the things that their
base wanted and then once they got
elected what's the party then they come
back to Center and now it's like uh
we're kind of saying all the same things
but just a little Nuance now it's like
you stay on your side and you keep
pushing just I kept thinking in 20
seconds it just stays like that [ __ ]
y'all like it's great I kept thinking
Trump is going to come back to the
middle when he was doing the primary
Center watch it and then he just did not
yeah that [ __ ] is done that's crazy you
gotta let you gotta let other people at
least say some [ __ ] yeah because if
they're canceled for saying it then
other people are afraid to say it and
then nobody says anything and now you
just have the most extreme [ __ ]
who don't care saying it and they're
going to be looked at as Brave and then
it's the same situation we were in
before which is I don't care how
nefarious an actor is as long as they
Echo the sentiments that I feel that
nobody's saying
and
yeah yeah I don't know the solution 100
but I know at least if you let
[ __ ] say something and don't
immediately try to get them out of here
you won't have as far
I'll swing on the pendulum yeah or at
least try to teach them or educate them
why it's not without being [ __ ]
aggressive yeah yeah you exactly you
explain your point of view and have
confidence in your point of view and
have that discussion because if you just
go what'd you say you disagree [ __ ] you
you're fired you need to be canceled
there's going to be a [ __ ] with
some Bugattis yeah see and you know what
I mean and that's the sucky part because
then you have the guy with the Bugattis
and he's packaging this message in a way
that people are like frustrated and they
want to hear it but then look at all the
[ __ ] that he's doing behind the scenes
is like look at the guy who's telling
you these messages and and that [ __ ] so
what you just said I know about him I'm
like oh wow he's on some [ __ ] up let's
we gotta find out if it's true it's not
that bad
but like we were saying you're talking
about frustration the more frustrated
somebody is the less they care about the
person delivering a message that's true
and that's what it feels it feels like
dudes are frustrated like real
frustrated and they're just waiting for
someone to voice their opinion and or or
their emotions remember when we used to
say agree to disagree I don't feel like
I ever hear that anymore that [ __ ] was
whack though that'll make me feel good
nah but that's hey it's better it it's
better but it makes me feel I don't
think we're never never died look I grew
up in I go to that back that's my sacred
floor that's my sacred flaw how about
agree until you
tell you like I can't do agree to
disagree to save my goddamn life it's
the best because if we agree to disagree
I don't not a thousand people are
shouting at you and making you go that
much further that way hey we just don't
see eye to eye on this and we'll both
probably be right here yo if I yell at
you you're going this way and I'm going
this way you know the uh the thing the
thing that's helped me is
to get because I can't just agree to
disagree I got to be like
agree that you understand why I feel
this way you don't have to agree that's
fine just understand where this is
coming from and I'm not an [ __ ] or a
piece of [ __ ] or a monster that's valid
that's bad and you could think it's
wrong
and I'll understand like this is even
great when I'm like uh disagreeing with
[ __ ] with my wife on it's like at least
know I'm coming from a place that wasn't
a jerk and I apologize if I communicate
but like just know that the place I was
coming from was good yeah and I think if
if politically we could start doing a
little bit more that like why don't you
want to pay more taxes because these
[ __ ] in the government don't do
[ __ ] and then you go don't talk about
the government you don't care about that
cause I'm trying to keep all the money I
make that makes sense that oh that is
resonating now this rest stop talking
about the the government with the
bridges even if the government spent the
money so efficiently yeah you still
wouldn't want a Pam yeah like I still
wouldn't even black lives matter all
lives matter if you can understand why
black people feel this way as someone
who doesn't get it and be like okay I
see you on that and then if you like I
did shows in Toledo and I saw like
hopelessness there like I was this is a
city that's hopeless I remember thinking
oh I see how these guys voted for Trump
no but you know what's Phil hilarious
about what you said you said it's
hopeless like literally hopeless it's
hopeless the reason for the saying holy
Toledo is because there's so many
churches in Toledo
[Laughter]
I'm telling you and I made jokes every
show I did there people were great they
came to the shows but we just laughed at
how shitty Toledo is and so if you're a
white dude in Toledo and then somebody
else comes and says make America great
again you're not thinking about what
used to happen to black people in the
60s you're thinking about what our town
used to be you're not thinking oh yeah
that was great when we oppressed those
guys you're thinking you know my family
used to have jobs we said this used to
be a town that had [ __ ] manufacturing
now it has nothing let's go back to that
and if you could empathize as a black
dude with that and I said why did you
get empathize with a black person being
like no policing needs to change just
even if I don't agree I understand how
you got here
to what you were saying there we just
made so much progress but that's a group
of Maga that wants to go back to win
yeah
but I understand not everyone is like
that yo there's there's also all this
this you know this animosity the hot
chicks and don't get me wrong like these
like hot histogram thoughts they [ __ ]
annoying and that kind of [ __ ] but like
ask yourself would you not do the same
thing you know what I'm saying like I
it's it's really cool there are times
where I don't have to wait online to go
to a restaurant
I could yeah I could choose to yeah you
know what I mean I could choose to be
like no just put me at the end of the
list and blah blah blah and every time
I'm like bump a [ __ ]
I take advantage of that situation I
don't want to go back so it's like if
that hot girls that's all they've known
their whole life of course they're gonna
develop in a way where they're
accustomed to that the question is when
I guess the frustrating part is when
they have no awareness of it who's
giving them pushback
oh well I think a lot of it is like you
don't know what like a man has to earn
there they have to earn that is yeah oh
okay exactly
yeah I mean I didn't say it